let's go back even further though tell
us about this like the running man was
the real running man who went like this
little Running Man no and yeah I was
energetic I was passionate
what was that school is that like a
school talent show oh yeah it was a
school talent show in Italy and my
sister was a part of it it's an act
dropped out and so she asked me if I
would do it and big sister kind of was
like hey listen you're doing it and so I
did it oh so y'all are like close yeah
yeah so so I did that that show what do
you think my children will be close when
do you think that's gonna happen and
they're all like yeah well you know how
I did like it just happens and then as
they get older I think they get a little
closer it hasn't quite happened for us
yeah me neither but no but they're like
they're close but they're not yeah they
won't they love each other but you don't
necessarily want Thrones which one is it
which one's gonna be the ultimate who's
gonna sit on the Iron Throne r16 we got
sixteen thirteen too soon to be three
and one that just turned four months
whoa tired listen yeah she's like Connie
you're at home you get a chance to do
something versus like wait but yours are
all girls all girl it's a lot of
estrogen like like you and from hanging
out with all dudes to like just rockin
with women
pretty much yeah that's a lot it's odd I
just leave the remote where it is I like
my 591 so I'm not fighting that battle
I'm not all the we watch is animated
stuff so yeah yeah yeah so you probably
watch a lot of like more I know dude I
saw you singing Milan on carpool Carrie
was singing along with you dude you gave
oh how did I do
you did great so sweet to fantasy like a
grown man like my husband sings to my
children I mean he's you kind of have to
know like if you're if you're
you know I want to change the table and
you see them start kind of a sudden I
turn it I go from I turn from black
mamba to the white Mamba okay I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this